hi I'm Mai Yuko and I'm a yappy now if
you haven't heard of this term before
yeah P stands for young Asian
professional we're known to pursue
financially comfortable jobs not take
huge risks in life and overall just play
it safe I honestly don't think that it's
a bad thing to be happy nor is it
probably like a great thing either
either way I think this is the life that
my parents and grandparents worked so
hard for so I like to think that I'm
making them proud wait hold up but don't
they want you to do meaningful work that
impacts the lives of others well yeah
but I'm just kind of doing that through
like a well-paying job but in this day
and age don't you take risks to do
what's right for yourself and your
community even if it compromises our
financial independence because it's just
the right thing to do well maybe so
here's my story from a young age my
parents encouraged me to find a job
that's financially stable it makes sense
my parents were immigrants from Japan
who didn't have a whole lot to fall back
on as they raised me and my brother
while they were finishing grad school
the fear of the unknown the fear of
living as an immigrant in this country
where they had no roots challenged us
and meant that we needed to stay strong
to support each other not that things
ever felt super rough for me growing up
I was born and raised here and I spoke
English fluently so I didn't feel much
different from the white kid who was
sitting next to me it felt like I had a
pretty normal childhood until maybe
about high school came around and I
thought about cultural identity issues
but we'll talk about that in another
video
anyways I knew that my parents struggles
I would have to make it on my own so I
went to college instead computer science
to become a software engineer that was
like my goal in life for 21 years
go to school graduate and get a job it
was a straightforward plan to me and it
was simple but it turns out that when
you're striving for a milestone and not
a mission you can feel lost when you
achieve it so after I got a job and the
whole honeymoon period of working 9 to 5
wore off I found myself asking now what
was I going to be working 40 hour weeks
as a software engineer for the rest of
my life I mean sure that sounded ok
considering I never would have to worry
about money again
was I ever going to do something that
was sooo
we're out there and risk everything that
I had worked so hard to get yeah no
there was no way I was giving that up
but did I want to find a greater purpose
and meaning in life and figure out who I
am as a person all my values are so that
I could have a positive impact on the
world well yeah definitely but I feel
like I was afraid of something why
couldn't I just do it what was holding
me back well it turns out that it's the
same fear that kept my family together
the fear of the unknown the uncertainty
of making it through living in a country
that I called home once I realize this I
realized that every decision of my life
was fueled by a strong sense of worry
and fear I mean like going to CSD
because I didn't want to be far away
from my family
what about studying computer science the
job prospects were good and I was good
at math and science deciding to be a
software engineer well the pay isn't bad
these decisions were all fueled by my
worries would my family be okay would I
have any regrets in life will I be able
to spend enough time with my family but
also these questions make me realize
what's important to me and what I want
in life I think that maybe the emotion
of fear was a stronger emotion than
anything else and you know the more that
I think about it the more that I think
that this way of living is totally okay
and that it's okay to keep asking myself
these questions frequently I mean I
never want to get to a point where I'm
not putting myself or my family first or
putting ourselves in danger it's just
like not part of my nature to do
something like that but it is safe and
safe might not get me to the type of
life that I want to live you see my
biggest fear in life is dying without
having done all the things that I wanted
to do in life when I asked myself what
those things actually were I found that
some of those things were tangible and
milestone oriented getting a job
adopting a dog getting married having
kids but I also realized that I have
some intangible goals too like having an
incredible human experience and feeling
a wide range of human emotions or
getting to know all kinds of people and
very Millenial of me but having a
positive
impact on the world I want to cry about
things that I didn't even know I could
cry about and of course laughing until I
cried like a million more times and to
be honest I'm at a point in my life
where a lot of those tangible goals
luckily are doable but I have like no
real idea on how to achieve my
intangible goals
honestly I couldn't even put into words
what this goal were until recently
because just the uncertainty used to
scare me so much but realizing what I
want from life is forcing me to come to
terms with the fact that I need to put
myself in challenging and difficult
situations that I wouldn't have put
myself in before and I know that I'm not
quite ready to make like big risky moves
in life like I'm still gonna make very
responsible decisions actually making
videos is one way that I'm doing this
and I don't think I'll be making videos
necessarily like a safe route it forces
me to look at myself and understand Who
I am as an individual so that I can
positively impact others but yeah I'm
still very much EAP and I think there's
nothing wrong with that there is nothing
wrong with playing it safe you gotta do
what you gotta do but I also feel like
it's a waste to not try to understand
who you are why you are and what you're
gonna do about it we only have one life
on this earth and if you think about the
vastness of the universe and how
miniscule your life is in comparison to
everything else then you have a
responsibility to live it so that it
felt significant to you the person that
matters most
[Music]